outrage increasing over a controversial
plan by president biden's justice
department to investigate parents who
voice concerns about their children's
education the department of justice is
encouraging school officials to report
parents they see as a threat to the fbi
the new york post summing it up this way
are these domestic terrorists parents
have been speaking up at heated school
board meetings we've covered them but
getting the feds involved for many
that's a step too far republicans vowing
to get answers from the white house
this is a dangerous overreach by the
biden administration to sick the feds on
parents who simply want to play a role
in their kids education any time that
this administration doesn't like
opposition anytime it doesn't like a
political point of view they try to
silence it and they're willing to use
federal law enforcement power to do it
this is wrong this is against what
america believes fundamentally education
is the great equalizer but now we're
saying government is the only people
have a say not your parents what they
are saying is you take what we're going
to give you
if you challenge a government takeover
of your children
if you challenge what we are doing we're
going to turn you over to the fbi and
these past statements from president
biden are getting attention where he
promised he would not politicize the doj
i would not direct my justice department
like this president does
i'd let them make their independent
judgment the justice department under my
administration
will be totally independent of me
i will not direct them who to prosecute
how to prosecute what to prosecute it's
not my justice department it's the
people's justice department jesse even
jesse jr is old enough to remember
when the democrats thought that
president trump would weaponize the doj
it's funny that you said that jesse
juniors came out of his crib today and
he said dad the first amendment
specifically prohibits congress from
abridging the right of the people to
peacefully to assemble and petition the
government for a redress of grievances
now these parents have a lot of
grievances
because if a teacher tells your son
you're racist
you're gonna complain or if a teacher
says i'm gonna slap a mask on your child
for six hours five days a week you're
gonna complain if the teacher says your
daughter has to share a locker room with
a guy you're going to complain so
it seems like the democrats go out of
their way to protect the free speech
rights of terrorists anthem kneelers
statue topplers leakers and
pornographers but little miss simmons if
she gets upset about something at a
school board meeting the g-men are going
to come show up at her door and what is
the fbi going to do they're going to do
what they always do they're going to
infiltrate the pta meetings they're
going to entrap a soccer mom all walled
people are trafficking women and and
they're ignoring tips about school
shooters that's what usually happens
here i think parents should resist this
they'll become folk heroes if joe
biden's team tries to throw them in
prison for opposing their liberal agenda
and dana i don't know if you saw andy
mccarthy today
in the national review he's got a great
piece thank you uh one of the lines from
the fbi this is their mantra process is
the penalty so what they do is they
threaten these federal investigations
very torturous and expensive they
threaten indictments which can ruin your
life and that what that does is that
chill speech so they're basically
extorting silence from their political
opponents and no one's ever going to
stop them unless parents stand up is
there any role here for the fbi
absolutely not this is something if
there's a problem you call the local
police you call the sheriff's department
you call the d.a the last person you
want to call is the fbi because we
already know how they botched whether
it's the nassar case in the olympics or
whether it was the uh parkland school
shooting or i could go on and on the
epstein case and on and on they have no
role in this the fbi likes to get
involved where they get a lot of
headlines but let me focus more on the
issue what is important here what's
important here are parents have a
fundamental right to decide what is
going to be in their child's education
these are not people who don't have a
say it's their children not the state's
children and what's so incredible about
all of this is that we've got little
johnny who's coming home from school and
johnny says he's getting yelled at in
class he's six years old he wears
glasses and when he pulls down his mask
when his glasses fog up you know the
teacher yells at him to put his mask
back up you know and we've got kids like
this all over the country who are
spending more time cleaning their desks
than they are actually learning anything
and then we have the issue of you know
other kids who are now being put in
another kid an advanced algebra when
last year she didn't even learn
fundamental algebra because the teachers
weren't even weren't even in school i
think the teachers are the last people
that americans see as victims in this
case if anything they were made rich
during a pandemic they didn't want to
come to work and now they want to yell
at our children and there was a time
when they were celebrities they used to
be celebrities now kids see their
teachers on the street their teachers
don't recognize them because they're all
messed up they don't even know who who
they're who their students are it is
absolutely not the role of the feds
jessica is it possible to be charitable
to the white house and the doj that this
is yet another example of them not
explaining something well sending out a
memo and then not actually dealing with
the communications fallout
it's totally feasible and to become
something that jesse said you know use
the word peaceful which is critical to
the first amendment and understanding of
how these meetings should go we all
realize that even if you disagree with
someone you should treat them with
respect you shouldn't get in their faces
there's video of people of teachers and
school board members being accosted on
the street it's my impression just
understanding you know
president biden and the people who work
for merrick garland they don't seem like
irrational people that they are going to
be talking about folks who are taking
this to an inappropriate level versus
just someone who's saying excuse me i
don't agree with this bit of the
curriculum and most parents i think
should understand that the mass mandates
are not coming from the teachers
themselves that's coming from the higher
on upstairs but the fbi involvement the
fbi involvement doesn't seem to make a
ton of sense and it also might be one of
those things that we get upset about for
a few weeks it never comes to fruition
it was kind of an aside thing that
merrick garland did comment on because
maybe he got a call from the white house
and he was like okay fine i'll put out
the memo
but anyway they did it and it's got a
lot of attention and a lot of people are
mad and upset and they were mad before
but just this week president biden when
he was asked about the harassment of
kirsten cinema the senator from arizona
when she was followed into the bathroom
uh he said it's part of the process
right which was basically like saying
you know this happens to everybody and
it's okay it's not okay and uh kirsten
powers she's at cnn she said i had this
tweet which is worse your grandparents
being deported are being followed into a
bathroom because you refuse to stop and
listen by people desperate for your help
this is not a trick question wow yeah
and then i think when people
called her on this she said hey look you
know if kirsten didn't want to be
you know bothered in the bathroom she
shouldn't have gone to the bathroom
that's kind of like saying you asked for
it yeah and
you this is part of two trends biden's
okay with that but they're not okay with
hypothetical crimes what that person did
in the bathroom could be construed as a
crime coming in with a camera and
filming somebody but what you're seeing
is we are criminalizing the life of an
average american decent citizen while we
stop targeting criminals so now you can
shoplift anything under 900 bucks you
can beat people up on the streets in new
york you get out like that
but hypothetically you could be a threat
a domestic threat if they decide that's
the case and so what they're doing is
these trends are happening at once crime
is being decriminalized decent citizens
are being criminalized at the same time
at the same rate and it is happening to
um the fake feminist uh kirsten uh
powers do you remember her she was a
familiar face here always lecturing us
on how poorly women in politics are
treated and the need for grace it's
always it was always about grace and
civil life and then she goes after
cinema she felt the co she felt that
this was a cause for confrontation she's
a hypocrite but this is the same logic
that she's using like some issues are so
important that you have to confront
people that was the same
reason that ashley babbitt had when she
went to the capitol and she was murdered
an unarmed protester shot dead i tried i
did a search i couldn't find anything by
kirsten powers about ashley babbitt like
saying oh my god this woman went to
speak truth to power no pun intended and
she was murdered you'd think kirsten
powers would go like oh because you know
what they might share religious
similarity i wouldn't be surprised if
they're both religious but some but but
i think that when it comes to this
bathroom stuff kirsten powers isn't
turning the other cheek literally uh
she's made her name lecturing people
on grace and then she goes to cnn and
does an about face hypocrite nice she
deserves to be called out and it rhymed
it robbed and you know that was totally
spontaneous i